[Music]
all right definitely in the holiday
spirit with that song unofficial kickoff
to the holiday movie season but for
die-hard fans it started even earlier
lifetime in hallmark began premiering
Christmas movies back in October between
the two networks there will be 70 new
holiday movies out by New Year's Day
Niki batiste looks at what's behind the
movies growing popularity and how many
might be too many Niki you went to a
Christmas movie convention I'm jealous
Jericka good morning this was a really
tough assignment earlier this month we
attended Christmas Con in Edison New
Jersey sponsored by hallmark 9,000
tickets were sold for this now annual
gathering of Christmas movie fans some
of them we spoke to said they paid
hundreds of dollars to be there and we
wanted to know why this is one of the
coolest experiences I've ever been to if
you want to be the envy of thousands of
women just walk through Christmas con
with the heartthrob king of holiday
movies be a Christmas ambassador
Jonathan Bennett and if Bennett is the
king I think people love hallmark movies
because they make him feel good then
Lacey Chabert is the queen it's like the
perfect blend of brioche and cotton
candy I think it's fair to say you and
Lacey are the Royals
we the Royals I think that's why you
wanted to join the mathletes mathletes
you hate math Bennett and Chabert both
starred in the 2004 hit movie Mean Girls
but these days have found a home in
holiday movies yes too weird
it's slightly weird and they're festive
fans came to Edison New Jersey for the
first ever Christmas con to see them and
more than a dozen other stars tickets
for Christmas con sold out in a flash
passes for all three days plus seventy
five dollars but that doesn't include
the price of a photo with the celebrity
this guy loves all our Christmas yes I
do
Jim D'Angelo says watching the movies as
part of his holiday season routine there
is no denying the growing popularity of
Christmas movies since its holiday
season launched on October 25th Hallmark
says it's reached more than 40 million
total viewers making it the highest
rated and most watched channel on cable
hallmark is putting out a record 40
movies this year lifetime is also
premiering 30 new holiday movies and
Netflix 6 the merry movie seemed to fit
a formula a woman falls in love with a
handsome small-town man and even with
some bumps along the way they end up
together but fans we spoke to said it's
not about the plot this mother-daughter
duo came from Kentucky and say they
watch around 100 Christmas movies a year
they even traveled to a town in Georgia
where one of the movies was filmed but
the movies are not always reflective of
everyone lifetime says four of its
movies this year feature LGBTQ couples
in prominent roles and hallmark declined
to provide CBS News with a specific
number six hallmark movies this year
feature leads of color compared to
nearly half of the new lifetime and
Netflix movies Holly Robinson Peete has
two hallmark Christmas
movies coming out this season we all
celebrate Christmas we come in different
shapes color sizes so it's very
important for the movies and the content
to reflect the people that are watching
there are really sort of encouraging
steps being taken variety senior film
writer Matt Donnelly says as diversity
behind the camera increases he expects
it to be reflected on screen as well
Christmas is not just about religion
it's an American pastime there's
something really irresistible about a
happy ending and a Christmas tree
Melissa Joan Hart is the lead in several
Christmas movies okay you got me I
wanted to see if you had changed so it's
a break from reality this holiday season
is your cup of cocoa say okay then
Jonathan Bennett may be the perfect
temperature
all right well Nicki I guess there's
nothing left to say by that I really
just saying on national TV I did my mom
shaking her head
the Christmas con founders say they'll
be back in New Jersey next year and in
Los Angeles lifetime told us diversity
and inclusion are of the utmost
importance and hallmark said it's
committed to telling stories and
developing characters from a diverse
range of lifestyles and backgrounds I
know you know how it's gonna end it's
like I gotta keep watch it it's so
Austin s you know really steals from the
Jane Austen formula in my humble opinion
but these go all the way back to July
there's a July and Christmas in July yes
airy and they film these movies in the
summer so they said it's so hot fun fact
they use chipped ice that you would see
in a fish market to do the snow how
about that girl and the odd man out I
have never seen it now I'm Dick tit even
my husband last night so let's turn on
Christmas Happy Thanksgiving
hi Thanksgiving